Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Jagir Bayram.
Ich bin als Strensarzt hier auf der Station tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, guten Tag Herr Doktor. Ja, natürlich.
Das sind ein guter Arzt.
Ich hoffe so.
Ich werde Ihnen erst ein paar Fragen zu Ihren aktuellen Daten übergeben.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Herr Gauch.
Gauch. Können Sie Ihren Nachnamen bestellen?
Ja, Gustav Anton.
Udo César Heinrich. Gauch.
Und wann vorne ist Florian?
Florian. Mit I an.
Florian.
Florian Gauch.
Okay, Frau Gauch. Wie hast du ihn gesehen?
Florian ist ein Mädchenname.
Okay, schön. Florian.
Okay, Herr Gauch. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
62. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Da kommt das Geräusch. Was kommt das?
Da gibt es einen Geräusch, glaube ich.
Doktor Schalkens und Ihnen dieses Geräusch.
Ja, vielleicht kann ich so spren.
Was kommt jetzt auch?
Ah, das ist, okay, war das von Ihnen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 3. April.
Ja, 3. April.
1960.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin circa 1,65 m.
Und bei Gewicht sind circa 72 kg.
79 kg?
Ja. Okay, Herr Gauch. Was führt Sie zu uns?
Herr Doktor, ich habe seit heute Nacht extrem starke Rückenschmerzen.
Das ist so links unterhalb vom Schulterblatt.
Seit gestern Abend haben Sie die Schmerzen. Richtig.
Seit heute Nacht.
Okay.
Wie stark die Schmerzen?
Ganz stark.
Sie merken, ich zitte den ganzen Körper.
Ich kriege schlecht Luft, weil es zu weh tut.
Ich nehme schon Schmerzmedikamente, aber es hat alles nichts geholfen.
Was haben Sie angenommen?
Ich habe Ibuprofen, Nevalgien genommen, aber es hat nichts geholfen.
Die Schmerzen kommen vom Rücken.
Und strahlen noch ein bisschen nach vorne aus.
Okay.
Haben Sie in Ihrem Brust noch Schmerzen?
Meine Vorne.
Ganz leicht, aber ich sehe es nicht so schlimm.
Die Schmerzen am Rücken sind ganz schlimm.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass es einen Auslöser für die Schmerzen gibt?
Nein, das kam, wie gesagt, heute Nacht ganz plötzlich.
Ich bin aus dem Schlaf wach geworden.
Ich habe dann auch heute Morgen nochmal meine normalen Medikamente genommen.
Aber die Schmerzen haben nicht nachgelassen.
Können Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumper oder brennender?
Unter dem Schulterblatt an der Wirbelsäule.
Das ist einfach starke Schmerzen.
Das ist manchmal bestechend, aber starke Schmerzen.
Ich kann es schlecht beschreiben.
Haben Sie sonst noch weitere Beschwerden?
Aus dem Schmerzen?
Ja, nur die Schmerzen.
Aber das ist ganz schlimm.
Ich nehme noch zusätzlich Schmerzpatienten.
Ich bin bei einem Schmerz-Therapeutin in Behandlung.
Ich nehme auch chronische Hosehabe.
Ich nehme Oxikodon, ich nehme Gabapentin.
Normalerweise reicht mir das für die Schmerzen.
Aber heute Nacht hat es nicht gereicht.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Die chronischen Schmerzen?
Ja, ich meine das.
Die habe ich über 10 Jahre.
Sind die Schmerzen gleich wie andere Schmerzen?
Nein, so schlimm waren sie noch nicht.
Solche Schmerzen habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Das ist ganz schlimm.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Luftnot.
Ist die Beschwerden gleichzeitig begonnen?
Die Luftnot hat mit den Schmerzen angefangen.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein.
Bitte machen Sie etwas, damit die Schmerzen weggehen.
Entschuldigen Sie, ich habe nicht Verstanden.
Aber Erbrechen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise eigentlich ganz gut, aber damit habe ich kein Problem.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder so genommen?
Nein.
Das war alles okay.
Haben Sie Fieber, Stillfluss?
Nein, das habe ich auch nicht.
Nach Schweiß auch?
Nein.
Sie haben schon gesagt, wegen Schmerzen haben Sie eingewachst.
Sonst haben Sie Schwierigkeiten ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Nein, das klappt eigentlich ganz gut.
Normalerweise habe ich damit keine Probleme.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder mit der Wasserlassen?
Nein, das ist alles völlig in Ordnung.
Ich habe nichts.
Okay.
Gab es in Ihrer kranken Geschichte wichtige Erkrankungen,
außer Ihre Rückenschmerzen?
Wie gesagt, ich bin schon Schmerzpatient seit über 10 Jahren.
Aber ich habe am Anfang ein bisschen Probleme mit dem Alkohol gehabt.
Aber das habe ich jetzt ganz gut unter Korrektrolle.
sehr viel. Wie wurden sie behandelt? Alkohol. Alkohol, ja, ich trinke jetzt weniger. Ich habe früher
vier bis fünf Flaschen Bier am Tag getrunken. Jetzt trinke ich jeden zweiten Tag eine Flasche Bier.
Jetzt habe ich nicht gehört. Jetzt, wie viel trinken Sie? Ich trinke jetzt jeden zweiten Tag eine
Flasche Bier. Und wie gesagt vorher habe ich jeden Tag mehrere Flaschen getrunken.
Brauchen Sie? Ja, habe ich ja vorhin gesagt. Ich rauche sehr viel.
Wie viel? Zigaretten am Tag, brauchen Sie? Ja gut, eine ganze Schachtel manchmal auch zwei.
Und in einer Schachtel sind ungefähr 20 Zigaretten drin. Ja, ich weiß. Seit wann trauen Sie?
Seit über 30 Jahren, Herr Doktor. Nehmen Sie nicht persönlich bitte. Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Ja, ich habe das seit langer Zeit auch eingenommen. Es liegt aber länger zurück.
Das war auch wegen den Schmerzen. Da habe ich immer wieder auch Kokain mal probiert,
Marijuana. Und damit wurden auch die Schmerzen immer besser. Aber irgendwann habe ich es
keinen Sinn, bin dann zum Arzt und sage dem nehme ich die Tabletten. Ich habe dann zwei Jahre
eine Entwöhnung gemacht mit Methadon. Und wie gesagt habe ich Oxycodone und Galventine als
Medikamente. Haben Sie Allergie gegen etwas? Ja, ich habe eine bekannte Allergie gegen
Penicillin. Wie äußert sich die allergische Reaktion? Oder bekomme ich mal ganz großen
Ausschlag am ganzen Körper. Ich werde ganz rot und bekomme schlecht Luft. Haben Sie unperträglich
Breiten? Nein, an sich nicht. Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Alkohol?
Meine Familie? Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Ihr Vater, Ihre Mutter? Ach so, meine Eltern, das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, mein Vater hatte mal
ein Diabetes gehabt, aber mehr weiß ich nicht. Meine Mutter, nein, die sind leider beide
schon verstorben. Woran ihr Vater gestorben ist? Oh, das weiß ich nicht so. Wahrscheinlich vermute,
dass es ein Herzinfarkt war und meine Mutter in den Folgen des Diabetes verstorben ist.
Sie schreiben so viel auf. Was schreiben Sie denn? Ja, Ihre alle Informationen sind sehr wichtig für
mich. Deswegen ich notiere alles. Ja, wissen Sie, die Schmerzen am Rückkehr, das wird immer
schlimmer. Bekomme ich jetzt etwas dagegen? Wenn Sie die Schmerzen aushalten, können wir nach
unserer Untersuchung einen Schmerz geraten. Kann ich nicht jetzt schon etwas haben? Also,
das ist echt schlimm. Ich kriege schlecht Luft. Ich kann mich kaum bewegen. Es ist ganz schlimm.
Ja, es ist wichtig bei unserer Untersuchung, körperlich Untersuchung, ich meine, dass wir die
Schmerzen genau lokalisieren können. Deswegen will ich die Schmerzen nach der Untersuchung geben.
Aber bitte beeilen Sie sich. Es wird ja gar nicht schlimm. Okay, es gibt noch ein paar Fragen.
Haben Sie sich geschwistert? Nein. Wie ist Ihr Familienstand? Ich wohne alleine. Ich habe
nie geheimwartet. Ich habe keine Kinder. Was sind Sie vom Beruf? Ich bin Metzger.
Entschuldigung, habe ich nicht verstanden. Metzger. Wohnen Sie allein? Ja, ich wohne alleine.
Okay, Herr Goach, ich habe meine ganz wichtige Fragen gestellt. Haben Sie an mich Fragen?
Ja, wie gesagt, nach der Untersuchung gebe ich Ihnen einen Schmerz mit.
Ja, okay. Und wenn Sie keine mehr Fragen haben, ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Oh, bitte, gerne. Machen Sie auch eine Blutabnahme?
Ja, ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen. Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Gegebenen Fans, wenn Sie Bildgebende untersuchen lassen, dann werde ich Ihnen…
Was sind bildgebende Untersuchungen? Ja, vielleicht soll ich ein Ultraschall auf
Ihren Bauch durchführen. Aber ich habe ja einen Rückwändenschmerzen. Warum wollen Sie Bauchultraschall?
Ja, vielleicht können wir ein Torax-Frontkern untersuchen.
Okay, das finde ich gut. Vielen Dank.
Okay, haben noch die anderen Kollegen vielleicht noch Fragen?
Ja, leiden Sie unter einer chronischen Krankheit wie Bluthochdruck-Zucker-Krankheit?
Nein, das habe ich bisher nicht gehabt. Nein.
Meine Frage ist, hätten Sie schon bald einen Unfall und haben Sie Wanderschmerzen?
Nein, ich habe nicht. Unfallhatt ich keine.
Haben Sie seit einem Wanderschmerzen die Beinen schmerzen?
Ja, eine Wanderschmerzen, eine Note rücken, was wir tun.
Okay. Eine andere Schmerzen. Das ist mit meinen bisherigen Medikamenten relativ gut eingestellt.
Sie haben gesagt, diese Schmerzen haben gleichzeitig mit den Luftnoten angefangen.
Die Luftnot hat mit den Schmerzen angefangen.
Sind die Schmerzen belastend abhängig?
Wenn Sie sich bewegen, stärkt sich die Schmerzen?
Also, heute Nacht ist es anhaltend. Sie sind nicht weggegangen.
Das ist jetzt unabhängig von Belastung.
Also, das ist ein Patient von heute Mittag, der Wanderschmerzen-Praxis.
Das ist schwer.
Wir haben ein EKG geschrieben. Das war sehr interessant.
Das verrate ich jetzt schon mal im Voraus.
Der war Tariqat. Er hat eine Erzberg-Qüenz von 130.
Hat der Patient einen Beschwerden über Herzstückmüsstürmung oder nie?
Er hat nur gesagt, er hat nur leichte Luftnoten, leichte Zielen und Schmerzen an der linken Brust.
Sonst nichts.
Ihre Rhythmusstörungen sind nicht bekannt.
Aber im EKG hatte er einen Puls von 130 gehabt.
Es war aber ein Sinus.
Das war regelmäßig.
Aber schnell.
Was aber auch krass ist,
der hat ST-Hebungen gehabt über der Ableitung 2, über der Ableitung 3 und AVF.
Und von V4 bis V6 hatte T-Negativierung gehabt.
Woran denkt man dann, wenn man solche ST-Hebungen hat?
Wir haben die Kartinfarkte.
Ja.
Was war ein Herzinfarkt? Vor der Wandinfarkt, hinter der Wandinfarkt?
Aber ich wäre Passierend, hat keine Brust oder Schulte schmerzen.
Ja, genau. Und das war die Schwierigkeit heute.
Was hat ein Hinterwandinfarkt?
Hinterwandinfarkt.
Er war bei mir noch kreislaufstabil in der Praxis.
Ein Troponintest gemacht, der war sofort positiv.
Der ist ja körper und körper.
Wir haben den Notarzt gerufen.
Ich habe sofort gekommen, da war er noch kreislaufstabil.
Der Patient war wach und ansprechbar und konnte noch sehr gut reden.
Der Notarzt hat ihn dann versorgt.
Er hat ihn einen Zugang gelegt, also einen wehenden Zugang.
Er hat Infusionen gegeben, Aspirin, Heparin usw.
Er ist ins Krankenhaus gegangen.
3 Stunden später ruft er die Intensivstation an.
Er sagt, der Patient hatte einen Herzkatheter gehabt.
Welches Gefäß ist dann zu, wenn es ein Hinterwandinfarkt ist?
Wo sind die Kardäologen?
Sie sind kein Kardäolog.
Wo sind die Kardäologen? Hinterwandinfarkt.
Ja, rechtes Gefäß.
Rechtes Corona-RCA.
Die war komplett verschlossen.
Man hat das dilatiert und gestentet.
Damit war das Gefäß wieder frei.
Was ist mit den Patienten dann passiert?
Kardäologen wissen manchmal,
wenn ein verschlossenes rechtes Gefäß aufdehnt,
dann kann das passieren.
Der Patient ist jetzt schockig geworden.
Er hat eine Kardätheruntersuchung.
Nach der Kardätheruntersuchung ist der Patient in Schock gefallen.
Kardiogen-Schock.
Er musste intubiert werden, er musste beatmet werden.
Er ist Pradikat gewesen, er hat Kardiolamine gebraucht.
Pradikadie.
Die Intensivstation hat angerufen,
dass es dem Patienten nicht gut geht.
Ganz schlimme Situation.
Das ist interessant,
weil der Patient mit Rückenschmerzen gekommen ist.
Das Erste, woran man denkt,
das ist ein Hexenschuss, eine Lumbo-Ixialgie,
eine Intakrostalneuralgie.
Vielleicht auch die Sektion.
Oder die Sektion, genau.
Aber der hat hier auf der Brust keine Schmerzen gehabt.
Was mich aber etwas stutzig gemacht hat,
als etwas verwundert hat, war,
dass er schon sehr lange Morphinpräparate nimmt.
Oxycodone und Gabapentin,
das sind ja schon sehr starke Medikamente gegen Schmerzen.
Und dass er trotzdem sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen hatte.
Trotz den Morphinpräparaten.
Das war so eine Überlegung.
Erst nach dem EKG haben wir gesehen,
dass es eigentlich ein Hinterwand infakt ist.
Deswegen hat er die Schmerzen hinten ausgestrahlt gehabt.
Vorne aber gar nichts.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Patient gelorben ist.
Heute Nachmittag war er an der Beatmungsmaschine
auf der Intensivstation.
Ich werde morgen anrufen, ob er es überlebt hat, weiß ich nicht.
Aber das war heute Mittag eine interessante,
eine interessante Patientfahrt.
Okay, jetzt habe ich zu viel verraten.
Doktor, Sie wollen ja noch eine Übergabe machen.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen heute einen säumwächtig jährigen Patientin,
Herrn Florian Boach vorstellen.
Der Patient ist 1,5 Meter und 79 Kilogramm schwer.
Der Patient, der sich bei uns wegen der Heute Nachmittag
eine Schmerz der Hauptbomben.
Herr Doktor, ich verstehe Sie ganz schlecht.
Haben Sie im Moment eine schlechte Internetverbindung?
Vielleicht.
Man hört es.
Darf mein Kamera ausschalten?
Ja, vielleicht wird es besser.
Okay.
Hörst du sich jetzt ein bisschen besser?
Ja, jetzt ist es besser. Vielen Dank.
Okay.
Die Schmerzen hätten beim Schlafen aufgetreten
und deswegen habe der Patient aufgewacht.
Seid ihr begleitet?
Ja, seid ihr aufgewacht?
Ja.
Der Patient außerdem klackte über die Düse und die Schmerzen würden nach vorne strahlen.
Okay, wo sind die Schmerzen genau?
Die Schmerzen liegen unterhalb der linken Schul-Tabletten.
Okay, ja.
Die Einnahme von Ibuprofern und Noalgin hat keine Linderung gebracht.
Hat es keine Linderung gebracht?
Die vegetative Analyse ist bis auf sehr unauffällig Anfärkungen.
Leider der Patient über zehn Jahre an Dorsalgie.
Da ging er mit Oxycodone, Gabapentin.
Und vorher habe der Patient Alkoholabus gelitten.
Der Patient habe Penicillin-Allergie.
Die allergische Reaktion äußert sich exanter Dyspne.
Okay.
Der Patient rauche bis zu zwei Schackelsigaretten pro Tag seit über 20 Jahren.
Er trinkte Alkohol alle zwei Tage ein Fleischbier.
Davor habe er vier bis fünf Flächenbier getrunken.
Der Patient habe Kokain und Mariana ausgeprobiert wegen der Schmerzen.
Sie haben den Patient nach dem Analyse Therapie mit Oxycodone und Gabapentin getrunken.
Der Patient hat mit dem Roggenkonsum aufgehört.
Okay.
Er sei mesker.
Die amnistischen Angaben rücken am ersten hin.
Die finanziellen Diagnose kommen vom Motoraxe.
Ich habe sie jetzt akustisch nicht verstanden.
Was ist Ihre Diagnose?
Die Diagnose ist die Diagnose, die die Diagnose auf der anderen Seite fährt.
Nur wegen Rückenschmerzen?
Ja, eigentlich gibt es nicht bestimmte Ursache.
Ich habe keine Unfall gehabt oder hätte.
Ich kann auch Milchlub dörfen.
Aber keine Unfallgeschichte.
Die Schmerzen sind ein bisschen komisch.
Kann nicht die Wirbelsäule die Ursache sein?
Ja, die haben sie schon mal.
Der Patient leide seit 10 Jahren durch die Diagnose.
Aber er hat gesagt, diese Schmerzen habe der Patient nicht früher.
Sie haben einen EKG gemacht?
Ich habe eine andere Abklärung.
Ich schreibe erst EKG und prüfen einen Parameter.
Wo werden Sie noch wissen?
Kardion, Kardion, Genie oder Herzwerte.
Z.B. CK, CKMB, Troponin T, Troponin I.
Zum Ausschluss von Pilomotorax werde ich Röntgen Torax anfertigen.
Zum Ausschluss von Erkungen wie Misshüfte und Magenprobleme kann Bauch und Trashat zuführen.
Welche weiteren Differenzialdiagnosen fallen Ihnen noch ein?
Ich glaube Sie nicht.
Nach dem EKG, wenn wir eine Myokart im Fark bestätigen,
sollen wir Herzkarteter oder Coronelangiografie durchführen.
Ja, klar. Wenn sich das Troponin positiv ist und EKG auch auffällig ist, was sieht man im EKG?
Ich erwarte Sd-Hebung oder Sd-Deplassmannsenkung.
Vielleicht Herzrhythmische Törungen.
Was sind die weiteren Differenzialdiagnosen?
Woran muss man noch denken?
Man muss einen Magen-Ulkos denken.
Man muss einen Milchrupter denken.
Wie gesagt, Pilomotorax kann sein.
An der Herzkrankheiten wie Pedikartitis oder Myokartitis kann sein.
Aber dagegen spricht plötzlich aufgetreten Schmerzen.
Okay, ja, das stimmt. Woran denken Sie noch?
Eine Autnisektion kann durchdenken.
Plötzlich schmerzen.
Was dann uns an Autnisektion denken.
Einiges fehlt noch.
Das ist nicht unbedingt rückhand.
Das ist eher gürtel- oder ringförmig.
Ja, Pankratitis kann sein.
Aber es steht am meisten auf der rechten Seite und gürtel.
Genau, er trinkt ja Alkohol.
Genau, hier kommen Vorschläge, Herr Pasztoster hat keine Ausschläge.
Ja, der Patient habe keine Ausschlag oder Hautprobleme.
Diese heftigen Sorgen oder Schmerzen kommen nicht innerhalb von ein, zwei Stunden, sondern ist dort eine getage oft.
Ja.
Sehr gut. Wunderbar. Also, ich fand es ein interessanter Fall,
weil der Patient mit eigentlich berühmten Schmerzen kam
und letztendlich hat er dann einen Akut hinterwartenfragt.
Fand ich ganz toll. Also, man muss daran denken.
Wenn wir jetzt kein EKG geschrieben hätten, dann hätten wir das auch nicht gewusst.
Und wir hätten den Patienten mit Rühmenschmerzen nach Hause geschickt.
Vielleicht wäre er zu Hause gestorben.
Ja, das geht eigentlich.
Okay, vielen Dank. Haben die anderen Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch Fragen?
Alles gut, alles verstanden. Der Doktor hat Patient gut untersucht, hat in den Leben gerettet.
Vielen Dank. Das war ein interessanter Fall.
Ja, ein interessanter Fall. Was ist in Ziffernfachheit, Herr Kollege?
Orthopäden. Aber habe ich leider mein Weiterbild nicht aufgeschlossen.
Okay, dann denken Sie auch an eine Protusion oder eine.